cambiamos de tema y vamos a analizar las
perspectivas del Ecuador después de una
jornada de elecciones este domingo por
un lado el expresidente Rafael Correa
celebró los resultados de los comicios
locales en los que su movimiento
Revolución ciudadana se quedaría con las
alcaldías de Quito y de Guayaquil y con
varias prefecturas provinciales Mientras
tanto se espera el resultado del
referendo planteado por el gobierno para
modificar la constitución en materia de
seguridad de democracia de instituciones
estatales y además de movimientos
políticos y medio ambiente la
conversación sobre este tema es con
María Dolores en miño ella es abogada
docente en la universidad Internacional
del Ecuador y directora del observatorio
de derechos y de Justicia bienvenida
Gracias por estar en France 24
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes por la
invitación Buenos días mire los
acontecimientos de este domingo
definitivamente van a marcar la agenda
política de Guillermo lasso quien además
canceló una intervención que tenía
prevista anoche empecemos con los
resultados para las alcaldías qué
implica que la revolución ciudadana se
quede con quito y con Guayaquil
Bueno creo que esta estos resultados
tienen que ser seriamente analizados por
el gobierno de Guillermo lasso porque
tras dos años de obtener una victoria
frente a la revolución ciudadana
parecería que nuevamente está
recuperando fuerza política este partido
incluso con con más fuerza porque
miremos por ejemplo el caso de la
alcaldía de Guayaquil que era una
alcaldía que durante tres décadas había
estado bajo el control del partido
social cristiano y ahora finalmente pasa
a ser controlada por la revolución
ciudadana el partido del expresidente
Rafael Correa y creo que se tiene que
entender en primer lugar como un voto de
rechazo a una gestión por parte de de
Guillermo lasso que ha sido por lo menos
insatisfactoria no solamente porque no
ha sido capaz de proveer a la ciudadanía
de lo básico para para sustentar sus
necesidades pensemos en el caso de la
crisis hospitalaria
la falta de medicinas sino también
porque creo que es un gobierno que
desafortunadamente no ha sabido generar
puentes conciliar Y lograr
al contrario de cómo se denominan a
ellos mismos lugares de encuentro y
lugares de conciliación entre las
diferentes no solamente facciones
políticas sino también entre los
ciudadanos Entonces esta estrategia que
ha venido utilizando el gobierno de
manera reciente con respecto a por
ejemplo referirse a la oposición en
general como narcotraficantes como
delincuentes el hecho de que tenga un
círculo de asesores y cerrado
excesivamente hermético el hecho de que
existan evidentes situaciones de de
rechazo o de o de exclusión en el debate
público a ciertos grupos que no son
cercanos a él termina hoy por hoy
explotándoles la cara con estos
resultados es evidentemente el fracaso
de una estrategia gobiernista que al
contrario de cómo se denomina el
gobierno dictó mucho de ser una de
encuentro es decir tiene que replantear
lazo Ahora la otra apuesta política de
la que aún no tenemos resultados es el
referendo sobre la seguridad Usted cree
que esta decisión y estas ocho preguntas
podrían terminar de hundir la imagen de
lazo o qué pasaría por el contrario Pues
si gana el sí
Mire yo creo que es equivocado Llamar
esto un referendo de seguridad porque en
realidad había solamente una o quizás
dos preguntas relacionadas con el tema
de seguridad que además no atacaban el
problema de manera directa es el caso
este de la pregunta número uno que
hablaba sobre la posibilidad de
modificar la Constitución para que se
permita la extradición de Ecuatorianos
algo que desde el año desde antes desde
ya varias décadas en realidad en Ecuador
está prohibido y y digo parcialmente
porque en realidad el problema el tema
de la extradición No termina
solucionando de ninguna manera las
cuestiones relacionadas con la
delincuencia común era una medida que sí
podía plantearse podía
implementarse y en realidad la cantidad
de personas que hubieran sido
extraditadas creo que no superaban los
doscientos
las otras preguntas se relacionaban más
bien con modificaciones a la a la forma
como se eligen autoridades de control y
el tercer bloque de
preguntas se referían supuestamente al
medio ambiente pero en realidad eran
preguntas que más bien apuntaban a
facilitar la posibilidad de realizar
gestiones extractivas en zonas
protegidas en Ecuador entonces hoy por
hoy al momento hay alrededor de un nivel
de escrutinio del 40% de las actas de la
consulta popular y en este momento y con
este porcentaje de actos escrutadas está
ganando el no en todas las preguntas que
también nuevamente creo que es una
suerte de contestación o rechazo a esta
política del gobierno que ha sido más
bien confrontativa que no ha sido
inclusiva y que sobre todo ya en la
práctica y para el ciudadano común no ha
sido capaz de responder a sus
necesidades básicas creo que el
contenido de las preguntas posiblemente
para el ciudadano de a pie quedó en
segundo plano con respecto a esta
insatisfacción generalizada con el
gobierno bueno Y además diríamos que es
una lástima porque es una oportunidad la
unidad perdida en términos de
gobernabilidad y de cambios importantes
para la constitución del país Cómo
afectará esto precisamente la
gobernabilidad del presidente que
finalmente tiene protestas en las calles
violencias y precedentes
y su pregunta sobre seguridad al final
Pues digamos que no aborda el problema
desde su raíz
y precisamente Y esto es lo que muchos
eh analistas hemos venido diciendo
durante el último tiempo el problema de
seguridad es uno muy complejo que existe
que exige cierta implementación incluso
de cuestiones preventivas
enfocarse en lo social por ejemplo y
aquello no Se abordó y se planteó la
solución menos la solución menos
efectiva posible digamos en este sentido
Entonces en realidad no era una solución
viable creo yo Pero además Creo yo que
la situación exige que el presidente
lazo se replantee en general la forma
como se viene relacionando tanto con la
ciudadanía como también con otros grupos
de poder y otros actores socialmente
importantes o relevantes
cierto es que los resultados le muestran
a él una dificultad de tomar decisiones
y un y una falta de apoyo evidente pero
yo diría más bien que es una oportunidad
para el presidente las para replantear
la forma como ha estado llevando el
gobierno y posiblemente enmendar ciertas
acciones para recuperar esta confianza
ciudadana que evidentemente se demuestra
pérdida con estos resultados